Speaker 1: All right, one more clip. This is
the last one from the Turning Point USA event
to try to indoctrinate young people into right
wing reactionary thinking. This is Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz. He has an idea. He says
that the only women who are in favor of abortion
being a choice are the women who would never need
an abortion because they're too ugly for anyone
to impregnate them to begin with, which is an
interesting, interesting theory for him to be
making. Take a listen to this. Have you watched.
Speaker 4: These pro abortion, pro murder rallies?
The people are just disgusting. Like, why is
it that the women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most worried about
having abortions? Nobody wants to impregnate you.
If you look like a fun. These people are odious
on the inside and out. They're like 5 to £350
and they're like, Give me my abortions or I'll get
up in March in protest. And I'm thinking, Marge,
you look like you got ankles weaker than the legal
reasoning behind Roe versus Wade. A few of them
need to get up in March. They need to get up and
march for like an hour a day, swing those arms,
get the blood pumping, maybe mix in a salad.
Speaker 1: Now, as absurd as this is,
if it were true, there would be no demand for
abortion services, right? I mean, like, it's a
it's so stupid. And of course, you know, it's
fat phobic, it's misogynistic, it's everything.
If only women who no one would have sex with
want abortions, there would by definition be
no abortions. So it's by definition not
true. And even after this tirade, after
this disgusting tirade from a disgusting guy,
women will still vote for him like it's crazy,
but he will almost certainly be reelected. And so
as a reminder, when you hear the things that Matt
Gaetz says and we say that is just vile, how,
how does someone like this get elected? It's
really horrible that he exists now. No, no, he's
not the disease. He's the symptom. The disease
is the people in. I forget what he represents.
Is it the Pensacola area or whatever in Florida
that the disease is that people will vote for him
despite these comments or even because of comments
like this, just this completely disgusting guy.
And this is sort of the new wave of Republicanism.
I am not praying now, now that we've seen what
took place at this Turning Point USA event over
the weekend. I'm not saying that I am a supporter
of the politics of the sort of Cordray of
Mitt Romney, John McCain, George W Bush, Dick
Cheney, like I'm not a supporter of that. But
there is sort of a battle for the Republican
Party right now where you have, on the one hand,
people like in the modern day Romney and Liz
Cheney and to a lesser degree, Adam Kinzinger
or whoever. That's one side. And then on the
other side, you have Boebert, Green, Trump,
Gates, those types of people. And there's no real
way to know right now what the Republican Party
will look like in five years. And I used the
number five specifically. That would be 2027.
It would be after these midterms and the next
presidential and one more midterm, that's three
election cycles. What will the Republican Party
look like in five years? Is it going to be more
like the Bush, Romney, McCain Republican Party?
Is it going to be an even exponentially more
cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs version of the Trumpian
Republican Party? Is it going to be a new thing
altogether? Will it split? We don't know. But
when you look at an event like Turning Point USA,
there's none of that other type of conservatism
there. There's no conservatism at all. This is
really just ignorant, reactionary thinking. I
don't know what it's going to look like in five
years, but it's going to be a hellish path for
the United States, no matter which way it goes.